you know how to suppose there are many
things in this world that are
indispensable but this old bird comes
about as close to it as you can get for
an airplane the kc-135 stratotanker and
it's used for refueling aircraft in
flight or we also use it in fact for
carrying cargo or passengers and
sometimes as an airborne command post
but when I say indispensable I'm
thinking of it mostly as a refueler I'm
Sergeant Novak and I'm a boom operator
on these kc-135 tankers I work with a
pilot a co-pilot
the navigator we're the whole crew just
before preparation contact sickness
final preparation for contact auto sick
set to ninety nine-cent copilot at 19
stay woke up
I'm going back now to refuel an F for
Street Fighter come on I'll show you how
we do it
and doesn't apply but doesn't require
your contact
now
okay host explore shag for an eye injury
I was saying a while ago these tankers
are almost indispensable for today's
their operation
you take aircraft deployment for example
you know how we got our fighter aircraft
over there in the Korean War we had to
dismantle them send them over there by
ships and then reassemble them when they
got there it took months but today with
aerial refueling we can send fighters a
place in the world in a matter of hour
like we did when we said that squadron
of f-16s over in Korea right after the
Pueblo incident most of the fighters and
reconnaissance aircraft involved in the
Vietnam War who over there with the aid
of air refueling and they fly back the
same way when they're due for overhaul
in the state on any given day
aside from mass deployments there are
always tankers and fighters going both
ways over the pot what the tanker has
done for us is that we are no longer at
the mercy of fuel duration commanders in
Europe of the Far East know that the
capabilities of the tanker can be used
to build up their forces in a matter of
hours now that's important because in
this world things move so fast today
that when you need aircraft if you don't
get them right away you can be in
serious trouble
as far as bombers are concerned they can
get to most bases without air refueling
however with refuelling we give them
unlimited range and save precious time
so we are able to send b-52s non-stop
and quickly to Guam in the US on a
regular basis many of the b-52s that go
on bombing raids in Vietnam operate out
of Guam it's a long haul from Guam to be
at Naaman Bank and there's no way to
complete the mission without air
reviewing
the b-52 in the 135 are designed to work
together they give us our global
capability they can keep up with us well
enough to refuel us at our air speeds
and altitudes they can refill us at
night and in all kinds of weather
conditions
there's a saying in the Air Force that
flying is 90% boredom 10% sheer
unadulterated
terror well ground alert duty is a
little less on the terror side and a
little more on the board inside but
we've got our work to do mission
planning things like that but when we
pull alert duty were pretty well
confined at the alert Shack
of course we find other things to do
some guys sleep
others work crossword puzzles me I like
to read however there are the more
energetic we have one boomer around here
that has so much energy he does all the
gardening around the building while he's
waiting for the klaxon on the sound
nuclear war broke out our bombers and
tankers would be off the ground long
before they could be hit the tankers
would go along to make sure the bombers
had enough fuel to reach their targets
in return
but the point is the Bombers couldn't
make it to their long-range targets and
back without air refueling the same
thing applies to fighters that bomb
vietnam targets from bases in thailand
the birds are so loaded down with bombs
they use a lot of fuel just getting off
the ground so after they're born about
and it's out we top them off with five
or six thousand pounds of you makes you
feel pretty important you see them come
up to give them fuel you see them go
away and you know you're a part of it
it makes you feel even better when one
of them comes at you after a strike and
he's got holes in it and he's dripping
phew and you're trying to keep him alive
getting back to his base after it's over
you know you've saved an airplane and
you've saved the pilot when you get home
sometimes you can't buy your own drink
at the club I remember once when I was
going in for refueling the probe on a
104 is very close to the side of the
fuselage just a few inches out and as I
got close I mean a rough contact and it
bent the probe in toward the fuselage
while I was sitting there wondering if I
was going to have to bail out or just
what the boomer is able to make contact
and Bend the probe back up far enough so
that we could make a refueling I'll tell
you the old member really earned his
money that day I was coming back from a
strike mission over the north and a
pretty heavily damaged 105 one day I had
fuel siphoning problems and control
problems and every other problem
imaginable situation of that kind and I
managed to rendezvous with a tanker ok
but we were right in the middle of some
thunderstorms and we couldn't refuel and
I was running out of ideas quickly
tanker guy said we had to do in a
mediate emergency descent which we did
and I hung right there with him I was
getting pretty nervous about this time
as you can imagine and we got down below
and leveled out and those tanker guys
took control and got me calm down got me
hooked up we had a slow way down because
of my my control problems he slowed that
big bird down and I finally got my gas
had about 600 pounds left when I finally
hooked up and then he stayed with me all
the way back to home plate I was really
glad he did because with the fuel
cycling problems I had I had to make
about five or six hookups in order to
make it all the way back they really did
a fine job for me I remember one day I'm
flying out of Yubin eight wing when
general olds was a commander then on a
strike mission about 20 miles north of
Hanoi all deppoh out there everything is
going ok who got the bombs off we headed
outbound and number four we looked
around he wasn't with us and there's
been a lot of chattering on the areas
you had
a little bit excited being up there
anyway and you lost sight of us and he
took off in the wrong direction
we had to had it on out east to exit out
over the Gulf and come on back and when
we coasted out he said he had us in
sight so we just continued on to the
coast and that's poor fuel check and he
had about four thousand pounds less than
the rest of us and I made the remark to
my backseater at that time we're going
to lose that airplane today because
there's just no way that he could make
it to the tanker unless we asked him to
do something different to come a little
bit farther north force we got on the
radio and started calling telling them
what was going on and number four by
this time was getting a little excited
in fact the poll poker string was
getting a little bit tighter and not
knowing just where the tanker rendezvous
point was he said he did have a carrier
in sight so the tanker pilot knowing off
where all the carriers were based out in
the Gulf there said just stay over the
carrier that he had come up in meeting
there's a little bit farther north and
they normally come up with post tractor
fueling so the guy was just orbiting the
carrier is getting down about 1,500
pounds getting hurt and for fuel now and
tanker said I have you in sight gave him
a vector right to the tanker and he
plugged up and had about a minute and a
half
fuel remaining and if the tanker hadn't
come in a lot farther north and knowing
what was going on in the situation there
we would have lost an airplane that day
and that night
number four bought that tanker pilot
many drinks did a great job point there
have been many many things
I run a tanker squadron and I hear these
stories all the time I'm quite proud of
our tanker crews they're always there
listening in on the fighter frequencies
I've never yet heard it said they didn't
go after someone when they needed fuel
young tire I want to tell you personally
how much I appreciate job that your
tanker people did for the fighters and
in Vietnam without the cooperation and
and a professional ability demonstrated
by these people I simply couldn't put
the bombs on to the target and I know
that I speak for every single fighter
pilot and all Southeast Asia that the
appreciation that they have for the
tremendous job that the tankers did
we'll always be grateful for the job
that they've done in our support I'd
like to say general it's probably a
mutual admiration society among the
tankers and the fighter crews I think
that the tanker crews are probably more
keenly aware than any other group of the
tremendous responsibilities that the
fighter and recon crews had on their
missions over the north they are keenly
proud of their achievements their
opportunity to serve the fighter pilots
probably one of the finest sources of
pride and highlights of their career
well I don't think many people really
understood the role at the tanker plate
and I like just recap a few significant
things on an average mission our
fighters were staggered in about four -
a tanker and they took on an average of
around 12,000 pounds of fuel and they
had to have this amount of fuel in order
to get into the target with them with a
number of bombs that they were carrying
and as they got into the target area
they had to use a B and when he used a B
the fuel consumption went up
tremendously and coming back out of the
target area they staged on to the
tankers again they had to take another
4,000 pounds not four thousand pounds
with mount fuel they needed to get home
and without this capability of the
tankers we wouldn't have been able to
get into these target systems under the
heavy defensive environment that we had
- and do the job and for example and
we're going after the pod aamir bridge
rather the toughest target that we ever
had you know was going to be critical
the timing had to be exact and the
professional manner in which the tankers
were able to take these people on and
staged them off of the off of the tanker
and into the target area and recovering
and take on these added fuel in order to
get home I think was the highest
professional standards it's ever been
demonstrated between any components
within our force and this relationship
of the tanker and fighter team in my
judgment have constituted a new domain
for tactical operations in the future as
a matter of fact prior to my departure
from Vietnam - begin
use tankers to refuel f-102 do close air
support and that's a new a new tactic to
come out of this war well certainly I
feel that it's it's most important to
note gentlemen are that the overwhelming
air superiority that had been
established on the fighter forces over
the north did permit the tankers to
operate further north and probably would
have been able to be accomplished or
done in any other circumstances too many
people think of tanker duty is being
hazardous and we don't think much about
it ourselves but I know a Boomer that
was in a tanker crew that got the
Distinguished Flying Cross and the
Mackay trophy and you don't get Awards
like that just for laying on your belly
and pumping gas everyone knows what the
Distinguished Flying Cross is but the
Mackay trophy is given for the single
most outstanding feat of airmen shipment
of the year this historic refueling feat
along with the professional competence
of this crew ultimately resulted in
saving six Navy aircraft and their crews
their outstanding aerial skill devotion
to duty and humanitarian interest in
their fellow servicemen reflect the
highest credit for themselves and the
United States Air Force
that's the Secretary General Lee Wade
once again it has been demonstrated that
you can continue aircraft and flight if
they're properly equipped for refueling
and sometimes you have to take
extraordinary measures to keep some of
them in flight you have to put an extra
refuel or between the main refueler and
the aircraft that need to need the fuel
I think this was a great thing that this
crew did and it's a well deserved honor
and I'm delighted to have the
opportunity to present these
certificates and also at this time to
present the crew where the Mackay trophy
which of course is too big for you to
carry around so we keep it here and put
your names on it thank you very much and
thank all of you for attending
as if we have multiple healings I bought
it between elements I stole the boon
come over for a cup of coffee
Thank You crews that have been flying
together for a while don't do much
talking during flight fact that somebody
else is looking on they probably think
tomorrow these guys mad at each other
something all that is inside of course
it's just that they've worked together
so long each man seems to know what the
other one is even before he asked for it
Mike on one mission
I noticed the Navigator was getting a
little grouchy so I gave him a cup of
water and he settled right down he was
thirsty but he was so busy but he didn't
even realize I put on like a lot anchor
duty
you're part of a team a team the Air
Force thinks is indispensable to modern
airport
any way you look at it I'm glad to be a
part of
you
you